♪ ♪ ♪
- Dina Gilbert, merci de nous
accueillir ici à l'Amphithéâtre
Cogeco à Trois-Rivières où vous
dirigez "Harmonium symphonique".
On vous a vu cette semaine lors
de la première avec Serge Fiori,
qui était ému. Il vous a
embrassée comme ça, serrée
dans ses bras.
(cris et applaudissements)
Comment ça s'est passé, ça a
dû être vraiment émouvant pour
vous aussi?
DINA GILBERT, cheffe d'orchestre
- Honnêtement, je n'ai pas de
mots pour décrire ce qui s'est
passé lors de cette première-là
parce que c'était touchant,
émouvant. Il y avait tellement
de... C'était tellement gros
comme projet. Je dois avouer que
j'ai même versé des larmes
pendant le concert.
(rire)
Puis ça, ça m'arrive vraiment
vraiment. Mais j'étais tellement
touchée par cette belle musique,
par un beau solo violoncelle,
imaginant les paroles...
justement de la chanson en
dessous de la lumière de vie que
ça m'a vraiment touchée de me
dire : Waouh! Je suis quand même
en train de vivre ça moi, sur
scène, ici. Avec aussi un public
aussi nombreux après,
on s'entend, des années
difficiles de pandémie,
où on n'avait pas de public,
où on n'avait pas ce partage.
Donc oui, ça a été vraiment
une de mes soirées, vraiment,
les plus mémorables dans
ma carrière.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Vous avez 37 ans. Vous étiez
même pas né lorsque Harmonium
s'est séparé. Vous aimiez
Harmonium d'emblée?
- Je connaissais Harmonium grâce
à une de mes soeurs à la maison
qui écoutait beaucoup certains
des CD. Puis je me souviens que
j'étais éeéeéeée par "Dixie".
Et plus tard, justement, à
ce moment-là, j'ai commencé à
prendre la clarinette.
De p p p p plus tard,
je repiquais ce fameux solo-là.
♪ ("Dixie") ♪
Donc, quand j'ai el l l l l pour
diriger ça, j'ai été fascinée.
C'est comme... c'est une cerise
sur... C'est le genre de projet
où on se pindididididire : C'est
vraiment... Je vais vraiment
avoir ce privilège-là?
♪ ♪ ♪
- Vous aé é é é é de votre
soeur. Vous êtes née en Beauce
d'une famille, vraiment, de
musiciens. À l'âge de 4 ans,
apapapapapappris à jouer du
piano. Vous dirigez votre
premier choeur à l'âge de
15 ans. La musique, pour vous,t,
c'est un appel.
- C'est un appel. Mes parents
n'étaient pas musiciens, mais
mon père, il voulait vraiment
que ses six filles jouent de
la musique. Donc, les six à
la maison, on a commencé à faire
du piano, faire partie de
différents choeur. J'étais
la cinquième, donc pour moi,
c'était juste tout naturel de
suivre mes soeurs aînées.
C'était facile.
Donc, c'est sur qu'à ce
moment-là, pour moi, c'était
comme une discipline, une
technique. Ah! Oui, j'apprends
le piano, et tout ça. Je n'avais
pas en tête que j'allais en
faire un métier.
À Saint-Georges de Beauce,
on n'a pas les opportunités
d'aller voir des concerts
symphoniques. On n'a pas c
immersion-là. Puis honnêtement,
à la maison, on écoutait pas
non plus de musique symphonique
ou quoi que ce soit. J'entendais
mes soeurs répéter l
de piano par jour.
(rires)
Ça se limitait à ça,
ma compréhension de la musique
classique. Donc, c'était limité
au répertoire de piano, that's
it.
♪ ♪ ♪
C'est au contact des musiciens
qu'on apprend notre métier,
qu'on fait notre millage en
quelque sorte. Puis je me trouve
vraiment privilégiée d'avoir à
chaque fois des défis, toujours
un petit peu plus grand,
un petit peu plus audacieux.
Et de sortir un peu
Québec, ça me permet d'enrichir
ma démarche.
- Vous êtes une des rares femmes
cheffes d'orchestre dans
la planète musique classique.
Comment brd d d d d d d d de
verre et les préjugés aussi?
Parce que c'est un monde
d'hommes, il faut bien le dire.
- Je pense que... Je vois dans
les dernières années qu'il y a
vraiment un désir profond des
institutions de changer ça,
parce que je vois de plus en
plus de place pour les femmes.
C'est pas encore tout à fait,
hein!
(rires)
Je suis loin de dire que c'est
réglé, mais il y a des
initiatives qui sont fai
♪ ♪ ♪
Puis je suis vraiment certaine
que dans les cinq, dix
prochaines années, en tout cas,
je l'espère, il v
beaucoup plus de postes
importants. Je dirais que
c'est la prochaine place. C'est
vraiment ça, c'est le point
crucial de :dedededededededes
assistantes des orchestres
régionaux tranquillement pour
avoir des directrices musicales,
mais des points d'importance,
des s s s s s s s s s auprès
d'orchestres prestigieux,
c'est ça le point majeur.
Je pense qu'il va falloir faire
en sorte que toute l'industriele
renouveler pour pouvoir
finalement respecter dans
le fond le fait qu'il y a
vraiment beaucoup de femmesrereà
qui est passionnant.
- Sur Facebook, vous avez
partagé avec vos admirateurs et
admiratrices que vous étiezatats
quelle mesure ça a orienté
votre carrière et changé vos
plans pour la suite des choses?
- Honnêtement, là, je me sens
assez bien dans le sens que
j'étais encore... à avoir
certains traitements qui sont à
venir. Mais j'ai pu poursuivre
mes activités professionnelles
entre l'agenda qui complexe,
puis dans ce qu'on a plus de
contrôle là-dessus, mais
j'ai été assez chanceuse pour
certaines choses.
ce que ça a changé, ça m'a
encore m'a encore plus mis dans
le moment présent d'apprécier
chaque chose
Puis sinon, je pense, c'est le
fait que... comme cheffe, on est
tellement habitué d'être en
maîtrisenenenenenenenenenents
que là, pour une des rares fois
de ma vie, j'en avais vraiment
pas!
(r
Mais c'est avec toute humilité
que je pense que, t'sais... Dans
le sens que tu te dis, après çac
un oeil différent.
♪ ♪ ♪
Je me rends compte encore plus à
quel point la musique est
thérapeutique, puis elle est
thérapeutique pour moi parce que
pendant que je fais mon métier,
je ne pense pas à ça. Je n'ai
pas de douleur ou quoi que
ce soit, je veux dire, je suis
vraiment juste dans le moment de
la musique. Puis je pense que
le fait d'avoir le partage du
public aussi, ça nous donne
vraiment beaucoup d'énergie.
Donc je pense que là, c'est
comme un bon cycle qui se passe
présentement, qui fait en sorte
que je suis énergisée à chaque
concert.
- Dina Gilbert, merci beaucoup.
- Merci à vous!
♪ ♪ ♪